symptoms
as it takes time for a post covert 19
condition to be diagnosed
much of our current understanding of it
it comes from research conducted before
the emergence of the omicron variant in
late november 2021
studies from the pre-omicron period
suggest that approximately 30 to 40
percent of individuals who were not
hospitalized for the initial covet 19
infection
still had one or more symptoms 12 weeks
after the acute infection
that proportion may be even higher among
people who are hospitalized during the
initial covert 19 infection
evidence today also indicates a higher
prevalence of post-covering condition
among females compared to males
one of the ways we're seeking to bolster
the evidence base is through surveys
such as the canadian covet 19 antibody
and health survey
the public health agency of canada
statistics canada and the covet 19
immunity task force launched the second
cycle of the survey in april 2022 and
the third cycle will launch this month
its primary objectives are to estimate
the prevalence of pose cover 19
condition among adults in canada and to
provide information on risk factors
symptoms including severity and duration
and impact on daily functioning
if you receive an invitation to
participate in this survey in the mail i
strongly encourage you to participate
data collected through this initiative
will not only help us improve our
estimates but will also help inform
public health decision making to support
those affected by the longer-term
effects of coven-19 infection
for now we know the best way to reduce
the risk of post covenanting condition
is to avoid getting a covert 19
infection
and early evidence suggests that
vaccination with two doses of covet 19
vaccine may help reduce the risk of
developing co post cover 19 condition if
you subsequently become infected
if you are experiencing new or lingering
symptoms months after a covenant
infection please know there is help
available reach out to your health care
provider or local health resources who
can help you get the support you need
and assist you in managing your symptoms
for more information and links to
resources visit the canada.ca webpage on
post covert 19 condition which also
includes related links to a number of
patient-led groups that can
that you can reach out to for support
with covert 19 other respiratory viruses
and emerging issues like monkey parks
being current concerns in canada it is
reassuring to know that our covenanting
protective practices can help reduce the
risk of infection
and spread for all
and spread for all these diseases
this means continuing with our good
habits like keeping recommended
vaccinations up to date
remaining aware of disease activity in
the local area and continuing to take
personal precautions including staying
home if you're symptomatic or test
positive
improving ventilation and continue to
wear a mask in shared indoor or crowded
spaces around people you don't live with
we continue to work with provinces and
territories and partners to respond to
the evolving monkey park situation
at present
at least 550 confirmed cases of monkey
pox have been reported from 30
non-endemic countries worldwide
in canada
as of june the 3rd 2022
58 confirmed cases have been reported
nationally including 52 cases reporting
from quebec
five from ontario and one from alberta
the risk of exposure to monkey pox virus
is not exclusive to any group or setting
anyone no matter their gender or sexual
orientation could get infected and
spread the virus if they come into close
contact including intimate sexual
contact with an infected person or their
contaminated objects
we will be pleased to answer any
questions on monkey parks today thank
you merci magritch
good morning
symptoms
is
hospital
oh
foreign
foreign
community
foreign
foreign
thank you very much dr tam and dr new i
would now invite to participants to use
the raise hand function if you would
like to ask a question you can have one
question and one follow me
we'll start
hello good morning what type of modeling
are we doing in canada when it comes to
assessing
you know where monkey box infections
will be in the next coming weeks coming
months
and if we're doing that already you know
is there any early results you could
share with us dr tim
thank you very much david and i know
people got used to modeling for cover 19
so that's a very natural question
at the moment there's not enough
clarified data points to do any um you
know significant
modeling but our modelers are tracking
all the parameters
and
they're ready to do more
but i think it's just some of the
variables are not well characterized at
the moment the most important thing is
to get the epidemiology from the local
public health
departments just to verify
the critical epidemiologic parameters
okay thank you for that um
i'm just wondering like your role
is primarily to to provide advice to the
federal government if i
understood your role the last couple of
years dr dab uh what advice are you
providing to
politicians to public health authorities
at this point in time
at this juncture what are we doing
that what are we not doing what do we
need to start doing at this early stage
of you know these scattered outbreaks
that we're seeing
yes i think it's really important to uh
ensure that all decision makers get the
actual information as we have it so we
are trying to provide that uh in working
with local and provincial health units
so
it's important for everyone to remember
that public health happens locally they
need the capacity that they need
to carry out these
investigations it's important to know
and and and characterize the current
situation as an evolving one there's
many things that we don't know as yet
uh we have information uh based on what
we know
from the
behavior of this virus in endemic
countries but we don't know well enough
about what it would do in non-endemic
countries it's a neglected
tropical disease we need to have
better international collaboration and
support in order to collectively learn
together globally and so that's why
we've been participating in the
expert
meetings of the who as well as convening
our own domestic expertise
it is important to learn from the hiv
experience
and and learn to involve communities
right at the start
that are most impacted and as such uh
we're advising our decision makers that
we need to do a really good job
and and we are trying to do that now um
have been doing in connecting with
uh
stakeholder groups um in the risk that's
in in the um
people most impacted at the moment and
sharing information giving them toolkits
that they need to
spread the information and
on how to reduce the risk of
transmission
i think at this point in time it is
important to act fast and urgently to
stop the chains of transmission
at the moment it hasn't
gone much beyond the initial risk groups
but it could happen
and we need to be ready for that
and so
these are the many things that
we advise
our minister about
thank you very much
our next question will be from pierre
cinono from the lab press canadian
yes
um
foreign
foreign
uh
population as well
us about people is received a variola
vaccine in the 70s
vaccine that was obtained
uh
uh our next question will come from adam
hercules from the new brunswick
telegraph journal
hi there thanks for taking our questions
new brunswick's health minister
reported a first suspected case of
monkey pox in new brunswick yesterday
but public health in the province then
said this morning that it was confirmed
to be negative
that said officials added that the
person wasn't assessed until after their
symptoms faded
and then meanwhile the patient's travel
history and clinical photos suggested it
was a case i wanted to know if you have
any information on this and do you
believe there has been a spread
of monkey pox to the atlantic region
thank you for the question we have no
confirmed cases
in the ruins brunswick
or the in the atlantic region at this
point but i think it's it's really
important that
awareness increases so
it is helpful for people just
and journalists to make sure the
population understands
um the condition and what we're dealing
with
there are of course some um other
diseases that have uh rashes and
um
and
could potentially look like monkey parks
and that's why you need a laboratory
diagnosis
and we provided um you know guidance out
to the provinces and others on how to
take samples and how to get
those samples diagnosed but it is based
the confirmed cases are based on an
actual laboratory confirmation and as
far as i know there's been no cases to
date
thank you um
follow up
has public health distributed any small
box vaccine to atlantic canada
um how much and and where
so um we have messaged the provinces
that if they need to have vaccines
prepositions we are ready to help
um so this is a bilateral discussion
between each of the jurisdictions
we can get vaccines to them pretty fast
but it is good to have some prepositions
so
those conversations are ongoing
as far
dr new i don't know if you have any
further information about um the
atlantic region
no it's dr neward nothing additional to
add it's it's a very live conversation
and certainly uh uh we've engaged with
all of the provinces and territories and
to varying degrees depending on sort of
a
readiness to accept you know looking at
the
logistical chain of in terms of how
quickly we can get the vaccines there
it's a combination of all those factors
that
obviously our program staff are
obviously discussing with their
counterparts in each of the provinces
and territories thanks
thank you our next question will come
from melissa trepanyi from radio canada
melissa
uh
um
um
thank you our next question will come
from karen mckinley who i believe is
from the brandon's son
uh good morning and thank you so much
for uh
taking our calls um i was just wondering
we've had some issues with uh
unreliable data especially here in
manitoba
and it's it's constantly being tweaked
so i'm just wondering does that affect
um maybe the the federal tracking of
covid uh cases
thank you for the question and
once again i just want to emphasize that
we need to continue to support the
public health system in in terms of
data um acquisition and sharing and we
can't
you know suddenly the pandemic people
perceive it as being over when it's not
and then down tooling on the support and
the resources
to provide that information
um i i think that as we all know we
we're doing
surveillance
monitoring to to look at trends and
making sure that we have enough samples
for that
um we're not detecting every case as
everyone can imagine but
we want to get enough
information enough samples enough
epidemiologic data so that trends can be
managed
and in some ways that's why we've been
increasing wastewater surveillance for
example if um of course people are not
getting tested or diagnosed
but i know that um
you know there may be i don't actually
know the specific details um relation to
the province that you're talking about
but we're always there to try and
facilitate and support
them as as needed in terms of getting
their data system
supported as well but yeah i mean that
there's there's a lot of recommendations
i think if people have have not read the
pan canadian health data strategy and
the recommendations of the external
advisory group they should because we we
do need a lot more support for the
public health system and the data
infrastructure
okay thanks for that
and maybe just a quick follow-up in
terms of uh vaccines for the monkey pox
you've already said that there have been
talks with atlantic canada
and uh have there been any other areas
that the uh the government has been uh
monitoring uh outside of quebec and
ontario
absolutely yes so this is a
countrywide um monitoring and alerting
um
approach so
we convened all the chief medical
officers the special advisory committee
um and um have connected with every
jurisdiction
uh shared uh case definitions
uh how to report cases
and um laboratory capacity development
so that samples don't have to
necessarily be sent to
the microbiology lab in
the national microbiology lab in
winnipeg so all this is
being
rapidly
increased in terms of our capacity but
every jurisdiction needs to be on alert
and look up for cases
and they are following them up as you've
seen there are cases being ruled out too
and uh so so i think the system is
working uh but we need everybody to
collaborate including the public if they
think they may be a contact if or if
they think they have um uh symptoms
and so every province um and the
discussion about vaccines and vaccine
pre-positioning is being done with every
jurisdiction
okay
thank you dr tam uh our next question
will come from olivier ferron jose from
taylor
the question is from tva
oui bonjour
yeah
considerations that they might take into
account before making a decision
i'm
going to ask a couple questions from the
moderator's chair but before i do that
if anybody who has not asked a question
would still like to please raise your
hand and we might have a bit of extra
time for second questions if others
would like to raise their hand again um
but my first question i think is
um about the fourth dose rollout for
covid um there's different
recommendations in different provinces
i'm just wondering from your perspective
dr tam when the best timing would be to
have fourth doses for sort of the
general population not high-risk
populations and if uh if you think that
that has uh that time has happened now
or if there's a time in the future you
think that would be a better time to
roll those out
thank you for the question and i think
the national advisory committee on
immunization provide the recommendations
on the fourth dose which is focused
mainly on the high-risk groups and some
jurisdictions have
you know determined what those groups
are based on their own sets of
circumstances but also opening up the
opportunity for others
but it is more focused on those at the
highest risk some of whom received their
booster their first booster quite a
while back
now uh i think the timing of a booster
is important to consider um because as
provinces were opening up for the fourth
dose we were very much in the um
second omicron curve second second
omicron wave or this i i guess in many
jurisdictions the sixth wave
which impacted the way that um you know
people are urging um
to get there for those
i think um what we are trying to plan
with the provinces right now is the the
fall
so that um you know we can't anticipate
necessarily when the next um variant
might appear that is um
you know can cause another wave uh we
know something about waning immunity now
uh but
it's our best sort of estimate that
as usual respiratory viruses could go up
in the fall winter time frame so i think
our efforts are now focused particularly
on the fourth dose or beyond uh to that
time frame but at this point in time
though anyone who hasn't got their first
booster should consider getting that to
reinforce their immunity because the
omicron variant
really has showed us that that third
dose is important
thank you and on the monkey pox vaccine
i'm curious how you see those vaccines
being used i mean we're not doing a
wider scale vaccine of the population
and where our procurement of that
vaccine sits if we have enough do we
have to buy more to do what you think is
necessary with that particular vaccine
yes i think as everybody can appreciate
that there hasn't really been a
vaccination campaign for monkey parks
really before this and people were
getting vaccinated perhaps if they were
working in a lab or other a higher
situation where they may encounter the
virus it is not used routinely
in africa for example
the current situation is unusual as
we've said
and then it needs urgent attention
but is currently and i'm not saying that
that would stay but
it currently involves a specific
um
group of individuals that have um close
intimate uh sexual contact so that's the
group that we're focusing on at the
moment um and
there there's no um sort of essential
um
recipe or blueprint for a monkey parks
vaccination we're trying to learn from
other experiences for example with with
smallpox and and learn from the
international
collective from what we should do but
for now um it's really
focused as dr news said in french on
those who may have the highest risk
of
exposure the the intimate closed
contacts
and at this point in time i think that
is manageable and we want to keep it
manageable and break those chains of
transmission and we need the public and
and others to collaborate to help local
public health do that
um of course we're having further
discussions as are many countries with
the manufacturers to see what um can be
done about further acquisition
um but um that that's where things are
at at the moment uh but just the just to
remind everyone that the the change of
transmission can be broken by
non-pharmaceutical means
on the whole
i think the difficulties right now is
that it's very difficult to do contact
tracing
in the group most impacted and therefore
the offer of vaccination might become
broader
and related to certain exposure settings
as opposed to individual contact tracing
thank you i think we have another
question from pierre sanono from la
presse canadiens
uh
[Music]
um
thank you and i think possibly refugee
kenyan from cbc is on the line and has a
question rafi are you there
yes i'm here can you hear me
yes we can okay great dr tam i'm just
wondering you know you're
talking to people about
you know not getting infected by covert
19 that's the best way to avoid
post-infection symptoms at the same time
the public health agency of canada is
stopping the distribution of rapid tests
to provinces and territories and those
are right now the best ways for a lot of
people to determine if they if they have
colbit since pcr tests are no longer
widely done in provinces and territories
so why are you taking away rapid tests
i think rapid tests do play a role um
but of course primary prevention um is
is the best layering on those
protections including masks and etc when
you're in in close contact with others
not in your household
so i i do think back protest could
continue to play a role um and
you know that that's
important but it's not the only means
um it i think it rapid tests can
potentially change people's behavior if
they get a positive test
although
as we all know a negative test doesn't
mean you don't have it and that those
other measures
would also be extremely important to
continue these these personal habits
um so i think um the
i am not personally involved in the
exact amounts being provided to province
territories but you know at this stage
in the pandemic i think
the some of the roles and
responsibilities
are reverting back to the provincial
jurisdictions
okay thanks and as a follow-up just with
the spread of another infectious disease
globally so soon after copper 19
is global public health broken and how
do we fix that
well i think um
it is
emerging infectious disease can always
hit us
and we should be as prepared as we can
which means reinforcing the global
public health capacity so
we're only as strong as our weakest link
and capacitating um every country
to a
reasonable level is really important
so
i think
that
as i said
you know global collaboration and global
capacity building is i think
our best
measure against future infectious
diseases we may see more
and i'm not
not necessarily because of the capacity
not being there but it's just the fact
that
due to a number of factors
including climate change there's an
increase in human animal inter phase and
context
and so reinforcing uh these capacities
are really important right now
i think we'll see in increasing numbers
of these types of emerging infectious
diseases and with a good capacity not
just in canada but globally we can help
to manage them
and reduce the impact as much as
possible
so
there's there's definitely gaps i think
you've seen some of the reports um
globally
and some of the efforts uh at the last
uh
the the
wha the world health assemblies just
passed is about
how we strengthen
the global public health capacity
thank you very much dr tam and dr new
seeing no additional questions on the
line that will end today's press
conference so everybody have a great day
thank you very much have a good weekend
everyone